(typing)
(upbeat music)
- We started by
looking for WMDs which,
at the time, I assumed was a way
to classify yourself on
a dating site, right?
I remember thinking,
"Why are we searching
for white middle-aged
dads in Iraq?"
(audience laughs)
Doesn't make sense.
We've got enough
of them here right?
- He is a person of color
and he's more sensitive
to issues of bigotry and
I think he's gonna be.
You know, he doesn't
want to equate Islam
with extremist violent
people, you know?
- [Larry] Is it harder because
he's a secret Muslim from Kenya?
(Negin and audience laughs)
- I'll give you
guys the opportunity
to ask me any one
of these, which one?
- Islamophobia sexism.
- Islamophobia sexism?
I say uh...
Let's get rid of uh...
(Larry and audience laughs)
That one is hard.
Oh my god.
(audience boos)
No!
No hold on!
No you guys, you know,
we'll be right back.
I'll tell you in act four.
- [Narrator] Tonight's
topic is child discipline.
- How far should you go?
As a dad, I think the
most important thing
you could tell your kid
is, "Shut the fuck up."
(audience laughs)
I don't think there's any
better parental role model
than Fred G. Sanford, G
stands for getting my belt.
I acknowledge this might just be
a jive turkey issue, I get that.
There's all kinds of ways
you can discipline your kid.
You throw a book at the
back of a kid's head,
that's gonna get
their attention.
After it's gotten
their attention
they can read the
damn book, dig that.
- Can you just be,
like in a store..
You know, as a parent
and you see a kid
doing something wrong, is
it okay to tell that kid,
"You need to stop."
- I do.
- Can you discipline
someone else's kid?
- I do, but they
don't like you to.
- Are you cool with someone
doing it to your kid?
- Yes, and he's 22 so I mean--
(audience laughs)
- As a white bald guy under 40,
everybody thinks I'm
the kid snatcher.
(Deborah groans)
No seriously look, you
picture me and Larry,
me and Larry Wilmore
at a playground.
Granted he's got a suit, who
are you leaving your kid with?
- Health officials in
California are warning people
to stay away from
so-called measles party.
The get-togethers
are meant for parents
to intentionally expose
kids to the disease
to develop a natural immunity.
- Measles parties guys!
(audience boos)
- Yeah, you don't get to
participate in civil society.
- I used to hate it when,
you know when you have a
birthday party for your kid
and you have to make the
party favors for everybody?
And I'm like, "He's the
birthday kid, give him.."
So now the party
favor's measles?
(laughs)
- [Larry] That's their
version of a plus-sized model!
- I mean, that lady was
plus-sized from here to here.
I mean the only thing
plus about her was here.
- [Narrator] Is it odd
that a few weeks after
you move into the neighborhood,
Jon Stewart decides
he wants to move out?
(audience laughs and applauds)
- Um..
I would say that yes, it is odd.
I've said all along
that Jon is a racist.
(audience laughs)
Hey America, follow
the nightly show
with Larry Wilmore on Twitter,
but don't follow me home.
I want followers but I
don't want followers.
That's stalking.